[Musique]
ce vendredi 28 octobre 450 personnes
étaient conviées à assister à la
cérémonie de remise des prix des
Trophées des services à la personne
organisés par la Fée des SAPS la
Fédération d'entreprise de service à la
personne et de maintien à domicile au
théâtre Champfleury une soirée présentée
par Christophe béger accompagné de
Nicole Dambreville marraine de
l'événement partenaire de cette toute
première édition à la Réunion le
département a bien sûr répondu à
l'invitation à célébrer celles et ceux
qui œuvrent chaque jour auprès des
familles réunionnaises c'est une très
grande importance que le département
soit là ce soir puisque le département à
la compétence du social et les aides
ménagers l'accompagnement des personnes
âgées d'un certain axe dire et le but
aussi ce soir c'est de de mettre un peu
en valeur de mettre en valeur leur
travail les travaux que font les amis en
AM de cette cérémonie les candidats ont
été inscrits par leur employeur à un
concours consistant en une série
d'épreuves théoriques et pratiques
connaissance du public pris en charge
technique des gestes professionnels
sécurité communication ont été évaluées
en tout ce sont 11 femmes qui ont été
récompensées pour leur travail durant
cette cérémonie inédite sur l'île
il y avait trois catégories classiques
sur l'entretien de la maison sur le
maintien de médecine et sur la garde
d'enfants plus deux catégories plus
spéciales avec un coup de coeur et puis
un prix apprentissage qui est important
pour nous parce que l'apprentissage
c'est la relève et l'objectif était de
récompenser à trois reprises troisième
prix deuxième prix premier prix chacune
des trois catégories les plus
importantes c'était très très important
pour la Fédération d'amener les trophées
de métiers de service à la personne au
sein des DOM c'est la première fois que
les trophées étaient organisés dans un
DOM et donc la réunion a été notre choix
privil et sans doute que après on pourra
développer sur l'ensemble des îles mais
en tout cas on était très très attaché
par notre partenariat ancien à
développer les trophées de service à la
personne à la Réunion une soirée riche
en émotions pour les 11 lauréates
récompensées qui en plus de leur trophée
repartent avec de généreux cadeaux mais
je m'attendais pas du tout à recevoir un
prix du tout du tout c'était juste
participer et j'ai ressenti la pression
ce soir mais pas pendant le concours
beaucoup de fiate une très grande
reconnaissance à ma directrice Madame La
Gaude j'étais choquée parce que je
m'attendais pas à voir ce prix
même si je dors j'en donne tous les
jours aux gens mais je m'attends pas moi
je travaille plutôt avec les bébés c'est
pas un métier facile tous les jours et
je suis je suis heureuse et tellement
contente mais ça signifie plein de
choses ça suffit que être connu est
reconnu de son travail est reconnu de
ses capacité le métier une
reconnaissance qui fait du bien à celle
qui donne de leur personne tous les
jours au service des Réunionnais la
soirée s'est achevée en musique avec un
show surprise de Nicole Dambreville
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]